[Musique]
bonjour à tous nous sommes ravis de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau défi des
champions justin je suis heureuse d'être
défié moi aussi alors dit nous nous
sommes et bien écoute célia nous nous
trouvons à un pic à chambourcy c'est un
complexe sportif 100% fun ou en fait on
peut trouver une trentaine de mur
d'escaladé 90 façon de les monter puis
il y aussi de l'accrobranche
[Musique]
on a des murs qui vont se rapprocher des
murs la fiq mais on a également des murs
beaucoup plus fun et beaucoup plus
logique comme vous pouvez le voir
derrière moi on a des bambous sur
lesquels on peut grimper donc jusqu'au
sommet et ensuite se lâcher de tout en
haut donc c'est toujours l'idée du
dépassement de soi tous les grimpeurs
sont équipés de baudriers pour s'assurer
pas besoin d'être 2 grâce à un système
d'autos assurage sur le mode rit on a un
petit triangle avec une roulette qui
vont nous permettre
d'assurer de s'assurer d'accord
directement au bas du mur
[Musique]
maintenant commencer plus sur le concept
d'apic je vous propose de découvrir
votre vie
le défi c'est le speed klein celles qui
arrivent le plus rapidement au sommet a
gagné c'est un mur chronométrés
ça c'est l'état pas trop le vertige si
j'ai un peu peur mais bon je vais tout
donner un organe pas de son bord non
batta non plus le bon vin que la
meilleure gagne tu es meilleur gagne
allez bon courage fait partie du coup un
pied et une main sur le mur directement
sur les prises une main près du buzzer
vous dites quand vous êtes fret ou mark
kelly beaux-arts
de presse oui
3 2 1
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bien bravo à toutes les deux bravo il
n'y a pas photo vous êtes la grande
gagnante
merci beaucoup bravo justin ont bravé
coûte c'est bien entité bien l'avouer on
fait bien mais qu elles se sont pressés
les ébats une seconde près franchement
je n'y croyais pas moi même mais je suis
athée surface de contention et
merci